watch this girl
she's not acting this is the real life
Fallen character okay play this clip you
should just watch this I mean you're not
after you watch this you're going to be
into men just watch this God watch it
watch it
watch your facial reaction here what can
you tell us about how many people you
know oh my God as a group to face
indictments
look at that uh well thank you for
having me first of all and I'm I'm
hesitant to speak to something that the
judge made a decision not to share
he uh I don't know if everyone's aware
of this but there was a hearing
um
about what parts of the report should
and should not be published in its
various forms and the list well the
sections that were removed were
consciously chosen to be removed and I
don't want to say I have better judgment
than the judge
that's totally understandable is it
would you say when it comes to there are
there are indictments recommended look
at that is it more than
12 people is it more than 20 people
I think if you look at the page numbers
of the report there's about
six pages in the middle that got cut out
allow for spacing
it's not a short list
not a short list
oh my god when it comes to 75 Witnesses
like it is it it's not I assume of
course it's not 75 people you know who
she reminds me of how many guys have
seen the movie Wedding Crashers anyone
seen wedding dress tell me that one girl
I'll find you like holy [__]
anyways I'm into it Vinnie I'm into it I
know you are Vinnie uh uh you see this
with the story on what's going on and
and Tom I know you watched the news how
they were reacting to it and what they
said about this what are your reactions
well and mind you and Tom we talked
about this in the back she's the four so
this is for the grand jury for for Trump
so just let them know who she is she's
basically in church she's a four person
four woman for for picking all the
jurors and and keeping everything in
line she's the most biased there was a
interview there's another interview
before this one where she's rubbing her
hands and she goes um if Trump is going
to come in there she's like I want to be
the one to be like you know to give that
that brief that they do this is another
prime example of the bias that they're
used using on the left which is going to
hurt them because what they say Tom what
did um I think it was CNN or somebody
said she's ruined she's ruined the whole
it's a whole whole the courtroom thing
is all finished you have fair-minded
legal analysts that are on the left that
are just they understand how it works
when you go into a courtroom and they
are looking at this and they're saying
she is the defense attorney's dream
because they're going to walk in here
and say my client has been indicted on a
grand jury that had so much bias and a
violation of the confidential
requirement on the jurists
which one of these interview tour and
you saw Democrats that were saying she's
on this interview tour what the hell
what the hell she doesn't have a
publicist she doesn't have this they're
calling her up and they're giving she's
paid to be on these programs they pay
you to be on these things whether it's
five grand or 10 grand you're normally
paid and you've got these Democrats are
out there going she's on a freaking
media tour you can't do that as a Ford
person we work so hard to get this guy
on the mat and to pin him down and get
this grand jury to indict him and she
just blew the whole thing up right there
it is it's like they're they're worried
about it so you actually the funny part
of it the same facial expressions are
being made by democrats yesterday going
I can't believe this you know that we're
just a question for you you know you
know what I think about like you know
how sometimes we have somebody that like
tomorrow I'm interviewing uh uh uh we're
trying to get this on the calendar to
interview uh Tate's attorney right that
they reached out and so I'll be
interviewing Tate's attorney and I will
put that out live uh annual will see
it's going to be all over the place when
they talk about that so we we have
conversations before that interview
takes place so imagine you're the
producer working on that show and you're
checking her audio so Mary Emily is
everything good
you're like hey bro can you come and see
this girl
how's the weather where you're at she's
making these faces yeah dude I think
this is like
you know what I can't hear you click
right you can't have this person we got
to change bring somebody else into
replace us why would you even put this
on air this is not helping you out these
are just like these are turnovers and
interception that you just gave to this
other guy named Donald Trump and uh he's
gonna run with this when you see
something like this so look at Emily
cores the reporter does that look like a
woman that's reacting here it looks like
she had bad sushi at lunch and she's
about to just open her mouth and here it
comes she is in pain you see her sitting
there asking questions as this was
unfolding she's not Emily cores is not a
not a dumb person she's an intelligent
good interviewer
I'm not a mind reader but I'll tell you
she's looking at this going oh my gosh
Kate Baldwin Kate Baldwin it looked a
lot yeah Kate Baldwin looks like she's
she's getting sick so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign